welcome back to new rockstars news today
we're going to remember the og hero the
man the myth the legend the original
true believer Excelsior Stan Lee himself
we're also gonna get into fantastic
beasts the crimes of greenwald and
detective Pikachu and our ideas are a
new cinematic universe based on cereal
mascots yeah that's gonna happen joining
me today are Sam basher and Maude
Garrett hello I'm Eric Voss Phil
couldn't be here let's get started guys
and talk about our top story here
Stanley okay you know here at new
rockstars we love talking about
spider-man and the x-men the Avengers
and every now and then it's important to
remember that these characters and their
stories are actually created by people
of brilliant original creators like Stan
Lee and this week the nerd universe lost
Stan Lee one of our most important
creators he passed away at the age of 95
he'd huge impact on all of us everyone
here at this table makes a living based
largely on detecting Marvel movies and
TV shows and I know everyone watching
this video has their own stories about
how the man or his work at least touched
your life so we thought it would be fun
to look back at some of Stan's most
famous characters and talk about the
inspirations behind them
Stan Lee himself has said Marvel has
always been and always will be a
reflection of the world right outside
our window yeah yeah I buy the other day
before spider-man one of the most famous
characters in the world undoubtably oh
my gosh I think he's merchandise okay
everything else was created by Stan Lee
and Steve Ditko young people before
spider-man but just the sidekicks yeah
like you know you've got Robin Jimmy
Olsen all those little ones that are
like can I help and it's like no child
take a seat
yeah Stan Lee wanted to show that young
people actually could do more and it
seemed relevant in the early 60s that
that was a time in American history when
young people are actually getting more
involved in politics and protests which
is a lot similar to where we are today
as well also Stan Lee an Australian as
this is though it spiders were spooky
they are they can be cute with it yeah
they're a little spooky and then the of
the x-men created by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby which were inspired by the civil
rights movement before the x-men most
superheroes and super villains got their
powers by some sort of accident or
experiment but these were heroes that
were just born differently Professor X
also is said to represent
from Martin Luther King jr. and Magneto
representing Malcolm X which and also we
were talking about this before but it
was kind of cool that we actually got to
do a video with Stanley a couple years
back a comic book superhero based sort
of video we had to create our own
superheroes and they were sure goofy and
he has his own little easter egg cameo
on that it was a very magical experience
but he was very generous in giving like
he was great and he's I feel like you
know he's a granddad for all the geeks
and you know he's not 95 and it was like
we know it's going to happen we just
don't want it to happen but I was lucky
enough to interview him and I think it
was WonderCon last year um yeah it was
wasn't planned
he was walking through well like hey you
wanna have an interview and he's like
sure that sounds like fifteen minutes
and had a good old chat it was great
that's awesome
yeah he seems like a real I
unfortunately never got to meet the guy
but I mean we were talking about some of
these like the way that he was able to
turn x-men mutants and make them a
political metaphor for the civil rights
movement and that didn't just apply to
the civil rights movement in the sixties
like we saw in the x-men movies in the
90s and 2000's it was just a 2000 on
that it kind of became kind of a veiled
metaphor for the gay rights movement and
like it's been multiple generations of
metaphors that they can do there was
that joke and Dipple to where he kind of
runs up he's like you know x-men failed
a metaphor for racism in the sixties so
like all this stuff like was able to
teach kids about these complicated
social issues and and open people's eyes
you know to these very general
universally accepted themes that
sometimes get distorted through like
politics about you know just tolerance
and accepting people who are different
and something that makes you different
or subjugated it could actually be a
strength you know and celebrating that
and owning that and using that and
weaponizing it if necessary but there's
also characters like Iron Man you know
they were I remem was created in the
sixties well irony was crewed by Stan
Lee and Don heck Larry Lieber and Jack
Kirby and the idea behind Iron Man was
to make someone very unlikable become a
hero so you know he was a rich weapons
manufacturer at the height of the Cold
War but like Stan Lee taught up well not
to judge a book by it's cover and the
character became very popular and again
that's something that was like through
multiple generations like when Iron Man
the movie came out it was like right and
the height of American intervention in
the Middle East and you
we were hearing about weapons
manufacturers and and different
contractors who were getting really
involved in the politics in the
military-industrial complex so but it
was right around the time when you know
I feel like America started to wake up
maybe a couple years after start to wake
up to some of the things that we were
doing there maybe it didn't feel right
to a lot of people so it hit us on
another level with both in the comics
and watching the movies and it
resurrected a DJ's Korea yeah oh yeah
let's big-time it was kind of done and
dusted he messed up one too many times
battled some really bad addictions but
this movie put him back on the map not
only in this movie but basically
resurrected the comic book movie
franchise oh yeah yeah and I think that
you know there was a lot of huge influx
of tweets from so many celebrities a
Hugh Jackman even Ryan Reynolds everyone
kind of like wanted to say something
lovely about this man who gave them
giant careers and idj was basically
going thank you you basically you saved
me
you saved me in my career yeah and you
know like it wasn't just like Stan Lee
created a lie these characters he
invented the whole idea of shared
universe you know like that did exist in
some levels before but it was really
marble that was Marvel's brand unlike
some other brands of comics Marvel they
all lived in New York together and they
would go on adventures together and
they'd go knock each other's door they'd
hang out for a bit or they'd get in
trouble together they'd fight with each
other and the Marvel Studios brand has
been essentially the same thing infinity
war was the largest crossover event in
cinematic history right but that's what
the Infinity Gauntlet comic was it was
exciting to see all these characters
appear in one adventure together and
half of them die and it's crazy but that
whole idea of like characters existing
in the neighborhood it wasn't just like
a way to make money it end up being like
an interesting kind of theme you know
like yeah it's a community let's have a
conversation we're all in this together
to quote Prince right yeah I can't do
this alone
yeah and that theme has been running
throughout the Marvel movies like they
all start off alone and then in the next
movie they end up taining up with people
and it ends up where they're just 22 of
them in a movie and I think that's kind
of crucial to all of us you know it
takes a village he also created the
slogan to prevent villain
from happening and that is with great
power comes great responsibility it's a
it's such a great isn't that it's such a
good way it's a great much yeah but you
know let's switch gears a little bit a
lot of people are also wondering about
the character Stanley played in these
Marvel movies all of his cameos where we
know that he shot his cameo for Avengers
4 that came out this week we don't know
about Captain Marvel I assume if Captain
Marvel's raps probably there just hasn't
been confirmation we don't know about
spider-man far from home there's some
rumors maybe I'm also wondering if the
Avengers for cameo could go deeper into
that you know semi confirmed theory that
we've talked about before that Stan Lee
could be who uatu the watcher you know
we saw him talking with the watchers and
the post-credits scene for guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 or in this earlier
scene and then he shows a begin to
post-credit and it would just make sense
at least in a medical sense that this
guy's kind of overseen several different
realities and doesn't interfere he just
kind of like appears in different forms
and I will you know what the you
couldn't rag on the Marvel Netflix shows
a lot for like a lot of like story
reasons and acting reasons but also I do
like the way that they do their standing
cameos when they do do them it's just
they it's the thing in the background it
kinda makes like an easter egg of itself
like you you have to be on the lookout
for it so using that if you adapt that
in the movies it could be a very fun
Easter egg hunt for fans and make it
still feel involved and you're still
remembering Stanley whenever you go into
any Marvel movie because you're like you
know it like I know we were looking for
him physically like what kind of gag are
they gonna pull with him now but like it
would be very fun to kind of build that
into the fabric of the movie since they
already put so much effort into hiding
references to other comic books and
characters I think the goal here is that
we make sure Stanley never really dies
mm-hmm you know you should like his
voice is so present in all these comics
and you know yeah I think that it's a
great way what was it in Luke Cage he
was like in the form of a graffiti or
like a poster or something like that and
that was actually in Deadpool 2 that he
was like a big building in the Marvel
Netflix shows he is a cop on a
promotional poster or an in the a in the
departments it's Captain for Bush and
for Bush is a is a like a 4-dimensional
or sorry like a fourth wall breaking
character from Marvel Comics yeah well
let us know what your thoughts and
feelings are about sailing how do they
affect your life and what character do
you think who has like maybe a
real-world parallel applied to you and
your
life the most it did you have a personal
moment where you read Marvel comic that
Stanley was attached to and felt like
yeah this this does kind of voice my own
journey we want it we won't hear from
you like this is a time we're let's
share our memories let's talk about them
let's do our part in a few friends but
let's keep this episode moving on to
this week's a trivia question so we all
know the rules here the loser has to do
the same the winner gets to do the
goodbyes but just to ask the question
here what was the first comic book
written by Stan Lee alright all of our
questions and answers are in the bucket
here the loser as I mentioned before
will have to join our gift of shame to
do a goodbye as mole answer real the
answer at the end of the episode but
we've got some other news that came out
this week yeah the movie fantastic base
crimes of grins evolved babies coming
out this weekend how many people are in
this poster the answer is to me well
they cropped it it actually keeps going
about 25 movies all about Newt Scamander
and whose magical creatures they are
back we've got some fantastic or
moderately fine
beasts in this one now they're more like
pets though spoiler warning if you have
not seen this movie we're gonna get into
spoiler territory just a little bit but
let's just kick it off by saying if you
didn't want to watch this movie before
you're certainly not gonna want to watch
it now so this movie is all about the
hunt for Ezra Miller's character
credence with both sides Newt Scamander
and Dumbledore side versus grin divine
side trying to find him or convince him
to be on their particular side also I
think there's about 10 or 12
interweaving at once it's a little muddy
and I think I don't know I felt like the
movie was too ambitious if I like
Rowling was right in a biting off more
than she could chew so my number one
thing and this isn't like the anything
with writing the one rule you put into
is the kiss effect to keep it simple
stupid yeah yeah this is not simple I
felt like this could have been a very
good treatment for a book you know like
if felt like she was trying to write it
another book you mean she was trying to
do what she does and there was no other
writer on the
movie and I feel like there wasn't even
an editor to the script and they're like
we're just gonna take I imagined 500
page like a just a giant stack of loose
papers being dropped in front of all the
cast members and they're like we just
have to make this we have to because all
the other ones make money and so if it
doesn't make sense now we're just gonna
have to roll with it and the your
there's so many characters in this movie
it's it's mind-boggling not much money
there's so many characters that you
don't care about I think that's a thing
cuz with infinity war we saw you can
have two dozen characters in the movie
but we know that we've seen in other
movies you know more than half of here's
too many characters we don't I think she
over I keep blaming rolling who know
there's a collaborative effort but the
filmmakers here I think extended their
trust a bit too much with how much we
would know and care about these
characters journeys and what their
backstories are and they were
introducing mythology as if it was a
bombshell there's nothing worse than
like the storyteller feeling like this
is a huge important thing that you're
going to love and then yeah crickets
right and I think this story was just a
little over complicated a little it's
extremely complicated and for no reason
whatsoever and not a die-hard fan for
Harry Potter enjoy it just like
everybody else but for the most part
like I'm like there's a certain point
where I'm like I've read some of the
books there's no way they're ever this
complicated this is and it's only the
second movie in and also I'm gonna put
this out here really quick people are
already tuning at me because I put out a
review for on my youtube channel and
people were like no no you don't
understand like in books you have bridge
books I'm like no you don't you have
books that tell stories that are
characters on a journey yeah but there's
a story that happens during the journey
nothing really happens in this movie I
think there's so many smoke and mirrors
where they're like oh this is going to
happen and it's leading up to this big
thing and then we're finding out more
information and then I'm gonna
absolutely make all of that irrelevant
yeah and you're like so why did you
bother telling a story that doesn't
actually even really have an ending yeah
yeah there's a lot not fantastic about
this merely get rid of zoe kravitz
character she was amazing in the movie
but the storyline was irrelevant and
his brother Theseus and all your a
Newton sorry I don't like him I don't
like him as a character he's not a good
lead he doesn't look at the camera which
he shouldn't be but he doesn't look at
like sorry didn't look at any characters
he's barely speaking and it's like I'd
why does anyone like him that's a
reluctant hero he's super lucked into be
in a spotlight or to have any kind of
responsibility or to have like a greater
cause why are you building five movies
around a guy that doesn't even want it
well that's okay to have a reluctant
hero in the first act you know the
character who doesn't want to go on the
journey Eddie's not sure and then
something happens to make the hero care
about the goal and at no point does Newt
Scamander turn that corner be like oh
suddenly I have a reason to be part of
the story it may be a tough question to
ask you but was this something that you
did like about the film well here I'll
paint you a picture here I went and saw
a special screening thank you for the
invite and they offer drinks beforehand
I was the to Stella Artois in any
caliber yeah I think you could wake him
up a movie no no but here's the thing
sat down immediately you open with like
seeing a bunch of met of these fantastic
beasts and you're like wow I'm really on
board and I right off the bat I got to
say the CGI in this movie is some of the
most impressive CGI I've seen all year
and when you do get introduced to the
beasts they are very creative and I
liked that in comparison to the first
fantastic beast movie which had like 20
they threw at you and I was like oh wait
I can't I don't remember all of them and
this one it's like there's mainly three
that you introduced and they get like
they get highlighted and I really liked
all of them so secondary character yeah
because I think that's more of a problem
with the whole franchise but I agree I
think this movie made me care about the
beast so much more in this one when I
watch the first wasn't crazy about the
first one I think the plot was a bit
simpler but yeah there are too many
beasts and I I thought the lift knitler
was a little annoying in the first one
this one I love the nipple I love the
baby nifflas like anytime I beast came
back on screen the zoo and they
introduced that whole thing of the what
was that the the Kappa who has like the
water or head filled with water
apparently give those things that
cucumber and that like gets them away
from you it's
I did like the little tiny dragons that
would whip their tail and it made like a
little hard work yeah I'm like that's
the way to reinvent dragon sirs there
was creativity there and I wish it
stayed on that but then we'd have to
like kind of scoot over half these
characters of the movie also Jude Law
should get a lot of praise because he
was very intersex on screen even though
he was just playing himself dan Fogle is
a brilliant comedic actor and you can
tell I think that he was improving and
like just experimenting with some of the
moments and they kept them all know he's
just so brilliant it's really all the
performance is pretty great
no not okay well room to grow right we
got three more movies left in this
franchise that's a great takeaway from
this if you like this movie you're not a
bad person we still love the world of
Harry Potter but we have high
expectations and expecto patronum say
we're gonna say that was good okay I'm
done that one what yeah okay let's talk
about another thing that came out this
week specifically a trailer the
detective Pikachu movie we mentioned
last we just dropped a trailer and it
left us with one big question
since when can Pikachu talk and now why
and why does he sound like a man who's
gone through puberty for sure yeah like
a man-child
Pikachu speak once before in Pokemon I
choose you it's a has a sort of head
trauma believed a concussion and he
hears Pikachu talk to him or he imagines
because you're talking to him I've seen
this clip the audience loses their mind
over it it's unclear but in detective
Pikachu's trailer it seems that only
justice Smith's character can understand
them so can all Pokemon talk but none
have found their one human they can
understand them if so is this really it
really makes you think
honestly extrapolate when I deal with
Pokemon the last thing that I want to do
is think it's very clear just you go
find more and then you put them in your
little pokeballs because they're dead
fighting for you they've ain't they
don't die they faint not when I play
with them yeah
but I did want to say I did read an
extremely long synopsis for this movie
that was online and detective Pikachu I
believe the way I interpret it is that
he was partners with justice Smith dad
who is missing now and I believe since
they were partners for some reason they
could talk to each other and so now he
went to the Sun and so from familiar
genetic I don't know percent of the
hosts DNA yeah there you go it doesn't
answer the question of why the dad why
Harry could talk to Pikachu just because
they're partners I think I've been
partners with Pokemon before they will
not talk today will not they're pretty
reluctant but I don't know they're very
they're clearly much smarter than other
animals even companion animals like dogs
so it's okay I don't know is it okay if
they get trapped in those little balls
and we make them fight each other that's
gonna happen in this movie so we're
gonna have to ask a lot of questions do
they need like legal protection because
according to junichi Masuda who produced
Pokemon Sun and Moon the inside of the
pokeball is like a fancy little hotel
room but is he just saying this to make
us all feel better yeah probably yeah I
mean here's the thing when we when we're
playing this game as kids watching the
animated series it's kids you don't
think about it too hard it's just the
peer materialized into pink energy and
they get sucked in the ball and then it
wobbles a little bit and then it goes
dormant and then they're just there
they're like computer files at that
point I also watch at the same time as
Digimon so I think I just applied the
same rules of did you want over to it I
think they both didn't think it shows
but it is something weird with where
they do start talking to each other and
it's it's they pose that question in the
trailer right like why can't other
people here and but only he can like
it's not just familiarity and intimacy
right like Ash and Pikachu were that was
the closest on-screen relationship I've
ever seen I don't want to think about
what they were doing off screen that's
how close it was they couldn't talk
aside from when he banged his head and
the outer talks though I know there's an
explanation it's not it's not limited my
tongue right now solo episode there's a
solo episode where he is an outcast from
the other mouths yeah and then healer he
tries to endear himself to humans so
much by copy and what they do it's a
struggle it's like it jumps over the
of course of like several years receding
Meowth try to fit in with humans and
then it becomes the sideshow freak and
both sides scorn him it's tragic
that's the story we're going with
detective Pikachu goes with the side of
the angels and becomes a detective to
help solve crimes and rhymes city I have
a question hmmm Ryan Reynolds doesn't
need money no no no he's sitting good
yeah
why right well I'll be honest I do like
the voice and it did make me want to see
the movie because I thought the comedy
was pretty tight okay well the detective
Pikachu game that is based on the voice
actor has a similar one to what Brian
Reynolds is doing this but it's kind of
a gruff like adult man kind of voice
round Reynolds's Wain we funny we're
covering this story
three years ago when they were first
casting was Danny DeVito not up for it
dude if you would have been a lot better
I want to hear like Wanda Sykes yeah I'm
picturing like a Tommy Lee Jones like a
really rough like like an angry man like
a really angry man yeah yeah and I wanna
like rough somebody up or like an
influence that one that mean popped up
online I saw that one but - well you
guys think this means for the Pokemon
universe in general it is going to we're
gonna get a lot of questions when we see
the Pokemon have to come out of the
pokeball and fight each other it's gonna
make it or not feel good also based on
the community writing of this of these
these people they were guardians galaxy
as well I hope they show us what the
inside the pokeball looks like so maybe
we can feel better at home let us know
in the comments down below though what
you think yeah yeah but let's move on to
our next segment
I'm resurrecting hitchmate you guys
remember pitched me early days for the
show used to be called something
different here's the deal folks General
Mills the cereal company and while they
produce a lot of consumer goods is
soliciting ideas for movies TV shows and
web series featuring their monster
characters you know the usual suspects
Count Chocula Franken berry and Boo
Berry
guys they did not make their way to
Australia because we do not allow that
amount of sugar in children's breakfast
cereal yeah well words you'd probably be
a lot happier in there you would yeah
it's because it's a prison colony and
then one could see
hundreds of you mix their blood to sweet
so the wolf spiders come after you
Franken berries fingernails or
strawberries continue okay here's what
we need to know here here's the caste
breakdown guys just what you need to
know Count Chocula is of course a
vampire Frankenberry is a Frankenstein
monster Boo Berry is a ghost or ghoul or
ghoul Boo Berry wears a hat very
important and at what point Frankenberry
included a pink dye that made kids poop
pink you eat beets and you're like like
half a cup of red vines by myself that
one I called me I called my dad and in
tears because I thought I was I'm saying
that you were by yourself with someone
else the whole thing okay so the pink
poop doesn't have to be part of your
pitch but bonus points of it does now
here's the questions should these
characters be heroes or into her Suicide
Squad style who's a big bad of this
story are we think an origin story
Franken berry and Boo Berry are they
related are they dating are they both
fan casting ideas and cat voice these
characters Ryan Reynolds veto best shot
there's me baby alright so right off the
bat I'm getting I'm getting like maybe
like a Hotel Transylvania vibe where
they're all together they're all
together for some reason maybe like tour
that has more of a comedy but I what if
we had like more of a kid's stumbles if
in the way in the vein of Hotel
Transylvania where a kid stumbles into
like a haunted haunted house and you get
a oh here you go throw all that away van
Helsing we're getting we have to get to
that throw that way I want Van Helsing
cuz I want it to be darker you wanna you
wanna yeah if people like their dark and
gritty stories we have a van Helsing
type character you guys think about
which cereal icon bat could be let Break
about it no think about it you guys
think about it leprechaun from that
leprechaun from Lucky Charms that's who
it is yeah he's lucky he's hunting down
and he's got the luck of the Irish so
he's gonna hunt down all these monsters
because he wants to be the only
person who's got a monopoly on the
Sherman area he mostly [ __ ] crosses
Michael Fassbender Robert Downey jr.
Morgan Freeman yeah huh
didn't see the movie my question is
General Mills says way more fate like
lucky you got tricks bunny you got it's
like all the big good cereals the
cinnamon toast crunch there's a b-side
guys those cinnamon toast crunch guys
are now the Simmons choirs in the each
other my idea I want it to take place in
Australia plant outlawed delicious
cereal and and yeah makes you eat
kangaroo brats for breakfast and these
guys they're outlaws they're trying to
go on a PR campaign to get kids
interested in eating cereal and the Mad
Max wasteland that is Down Under
monsters are a threat there's nothing
else to be afraid of all right
mine is think Nonya but instead of them
instead of a wardrobe you're like
where's the thing that comes in the
cereal box and you dig a little deep and
then you're good oh and it's animated I
know and then you mate though we're wolf
my picture in green we need a bit green
in here and the where wolf is like we
didn't know where he went is you have to
find the way so it's like an underlying
message about kids eating healthy
because not all the time do you need a
bad breakfast all the time a delicious
way is the sugar
I want pivot right now pivot we get on
it wait sorry
quick question who gets sucked into this
world which major sports star gets
sucked into this world oh my god Oh
what's happens with waiting folks sorry
you always have big sports icons
Olympians yeah pretty love cereal yeah I
don't know sport either that guy the
tall one who's good at the bowl Michael
Phelps so this is gonna be like the next
Mike Mac and me right like McDonald's
made a movie that they try to make et in
the eighties McDonald's every time he
goes on Conan or whatever he's like I
gotta play with my new anchorman movies
just the cliff Mac and me it's like they
it's McDonald's funded this movie and
they eat McDonald's but the most tacky
product placement thing ever I really
like this is like move over Space Jam
yeah okay emoji movie kind of thing or
all that kind of stuff
yeah it's called lego movie which you
know it's an amazing movie that's
probably the best version leaning the
lego movie avoid Mac and me okay so the
last pitch really quick vampire sucking
all the blood sugar out of kids so you
can go make his own cereal the
Frankenstein monsters made out of
different pieces of people and needs
sugar to run so he can you know keep
going and the ghoul possesses people to
sneak into sugar factories to steal
their sugar and the van helsing is the
Trix bunny and and you can team up with
the Lucky Charms
leprechaun and the kids are chasing
everybody at the same time you know like
hey give it back the cereal and it's
like no kids cuz you're gonna die if
these these three get you Sam you win I
admire your creativity and giving an ass
it's really hinging on people understand
puns across all languages oh yeah better
translate that well let us know what
your version of this General Mills
cereal movie will be but let's move on
to some other news that came out this
week all those for a second yes Pedro
Pascal you know I'm from Game of Thrones
has been cast as the lead in Jordan
Favreau's the Mandalorian you know I'm
in love him as Oberyn Martell you also
know him as the guy who goes to my dog
park hey
this new characters gonna be described
as a lone gunfighter in the outer
reaches of the galaxy far from the
authority of the New Republic okay
the successful solar yeah that yeah it
to that cough yeah what were you gonna
see it cuffed in the middle you wanted
I'm also starting my petitioner need
your help if we are getting in the
mandalorian territory then satine kryze
who is the Duchess of Mandalore who
looks exactly like me she does bring up
a picture yeah look at that right yep
she was originaly scene in the Clone
Wars and she's has a bit of love love
time with them obi-wan Kenobi not the
smartest way to get to pass you in
McGregor get on it missing the show yeah
it's canon they did it also casting this
one is gina carano you know her as the
former MMA fighter who played angel dust
in deadpool she's been cast in the
Disney Plus series as well I mean we
have to get Disney Plus yeah I think so
I mean I was a foregone conclusion we
don't have any information on her
character yet though but look at her
she's gonna whoop some hands yes she
that's what she does she wants it yeah
so with these two casting announcements
are you guys excited do you like the
premise of Mandalorians so far yeah
subscription service one to all what the
hook us in yeah no idea I got my money
as soon as they like as soon as they
said I'm like I'm gonna have to at least
try it out for a month and then you
start hearing about all like the Marvel
shows and these in the Star Wars shows
it's like it's it's kind of a no-brainer
also Pixar has a vertical as well so I'm
like yeah I'm on board like a monster's
anchor monsters University show I'm like
you're missing out I surprised myself
gonna be less behind mod I mean Pedro
Pascal is amazing he was using Marcos
right my crazy was also in the second
King John movie has a fast-talking
already proven in their streaming series
this is gonna be great and this
baburao's behind this one oh yeah he's
sure winning and Tyco is gonna be
directing episode and so many other
I didn't say that so effortlessly I just
say it real fast and sounds right yeah
it's the trick but in other news this
week Disney applied for a patent for a
more realistic lightsaber to be used as
props in their movies and also toys
hopefully it toast bread I would love
that also birds-of-prey cast a
twelve-year-old Ellijay bosco as
Cassandra Cain also she is goddaughter
to Dante Basco Rufio Rufio
Zuko from Avatar The Last Airbender also
fun fact Jon Cryer of two and a Half Men
Fame it will be playing Lex Luthor this
season of Supergirl interesting and also
interesting choice Game of Thrones drop
the video looking back on their first 7
season and announcing that season 8 will
premiere in April of 2019 we expected
all right well lightning round time yeah
I'm gonna take control of this one
because it is lightning round for New
York now you guys if you want to get
your questions you know all you have to
do is tweet us you just Al question for
anyone who's on this panel I'm gonna ask
them they're gonna give us the answer
but it's lightning round so that's got
to be super super quick this one's from
app sergeant Cole beans with the new
live-action Disney movies coming out is
there any other Disney movies that you
would like to see adapted into
live-action mmm the schedule right I
want to see Lion King part 2 or one and
a half oh yeah I want to see that boom
ba-doom stern yes because Pumbaa is one
and mm-hmm there it's a it's a very I've
got one here at Zola
I'm just got 89 which is your favorite
Stanley come here how hi Stanley every
time I get out I think I've been asked
this question before and I always get
like the Fantastic Four the one from the
wedding oh yeah pops into my head let's
be honest it's him DJing at a strip club
oh it's pretty good yep
from at Rory Ragman Regan man hell yeah
what Disney princess and Marvel
character would make for the ultimate to
team-up ultimate team-up I'd say
Rapunzel from tangled so she can use her
hair to move around and I'd throw her in
with spider-man because I want to see
them swing around in New York that's
cute yeah Eric here's another one from
at birdie six eight eight hey guys I'm
not sure if you've already touched on
this but I was wondering what you think
about Sansa bran and aya killing
Littlefinger when he was a guest under
their roof isn't that breaking they
guessed right law oh I mean the rules of
hospitality must be broken especially if
you there's a traitor in your mist they
got evidence that he has he conspired to
work against them I mean ya know that's
read and changed everything with
hospitality yeah good question but the e
is a three if you were to swap
hairstyles with any of the MCU
characters who would it be
Tom Holland yes got really good hair or
star-lord cuz I want to do that weird
beard thing that he does like on his
like halfway on his face I couldn't pull
it off I've got one here from Maxie
Steinbach er which Batman would win in a
fight Christian Bale's or Ben Affleck's
Batman
Christian Bale he's good next level
psycho yeah yeah Wow
that wild yeah no amateur uh Eric that
was an HP he wants the no 1 killer sucks
do you have one right now black you
didn't even have to check yep I know I
only have like such as I double check
from 1994 what was the first comic book
that you read or bought oh it was Action
Comics number one new 52 it's wood
Superman had a t-shirt on it was a funny
what I related to cause I also owed
t-shirts oh good I've got one from Sandy
duck time for meeting will you do a game
of thrones rewatch before the last
season starts I will at least watch the
last season if not the last two if I
could do all seven yeah I would yeah
sick Eric this one's from Christian
92114 are we gonna get cap to say
Avengers Assemble in Avengers 4 we got
it right oh you must yeah
that's an easy one to start it in there
even if it's real it's a bit too late
for that
Sam this was from brother gamma which
star test which stock tech would you use
in everyday life I would get I would get
caps a magnetic shield bring her back
her thing but I'd do it for like a
cellphone or a wallet but hopefully the
magnets don't mess it up too bad all my
credit cards is from a dinner Deneb
tricks for Christmas what would you give
you a favorite superhero we all need our
oh well we're moving on to our 15-second
shout out sweet to us this 15 second
startup plug gramma buy anything once
Sam got anything for us set a thing
earlier that I should have mentioned now
anybody remember that one no yep not a
clue right nothing all right so I'll
mention a twit show that I host on
Wednesdays and Thursdays at twitch.tv
slash play noggin 4:00 p.m. PST I talk
about nerdy stuff play games talk about
all the superhero TV shows that we that
are on the air every single one of them
I even watch gifted and that one hurts
and tightens for my 15 seconds
[Music]
listen to the podcast last podcast some
left I think it's really great next I
create run produce everything a show on
geek balm called functions and flagons D
and D inspired except there's no rules
it's more improvements and bashes on it
hello there's a little bit of drinking
hilarity ensues there's lots of fun
times and I think we're up to episode 4
which is coming out earlier on geek
bombs patreon and then the public gets
it on Saturday in Devin's editing it's a
shout out Devin you can show your thumb
I permit 15 seconds for Devin well here
we go let us return to our answer to the
trivia question and we asked earlier the
question was what was the first comic
book written by Stan Lee before I
revealed the answer and what we wrote
the loser will have to join our gift of
shame draw a thing from the box do it as
a weird gesture and look goofy and then
you'll turn into an animated gif from
old tweet now it looks silly all right
let's see what we wrote first up I have
mod and she wrote Captain America he
seemed to like the older one he's a
pretty safe actually ya know Sam wrote
Archie to the Archie and Veronica comics
sorry Eric wrote Mighty Mouse well the
correct answer is Captain America foils
the traitors revenge wait wait in
America is the winner
I for a second there I was like wait
wait a second I was like oh you're
holding two different cards like alright
so um I won it and then which of us
didn't win Mighty Mouse er Archie what
does that matter how many issues of each
here uh Superman right on either should
we check that should we check it to see
all right so our judges have wilmot
obviously one Ryan kept America I have
lost I guess a Mighty Mouse wasn't close
enough so I'm not gonna get to her
goodbyes I am going to join her gif of
shape the way first the worst second the
best third
right so this lamp do I randomly you
taste something delicious followed by to
something gross followed by something
delicious alternating okay so just in my
head I just like tasting I have at least
ten ways I could use this gift later
[Music]
anyway thank you for watching this
week's episode of new rock stars news
let's thank our host today
you've got Erik Voss who's or reacting
oh no oh you didn't like that one
I'm Maude Garrett at Maude Garrett or
Eric I guess was a TA bus but I'm a
winner so I don't need to get everything
right and so Dasha at sambata comment
down below chat with us you can also
tweet a new rock stars like this video
share it around
subscribe subscribe to geek boom please
guys I II had 108 thousand subscribers
and now I'm down to 99 thousand and I've
already got the silver button and I
don't want to take it off my wolf but
hey whatever let's just not pretend that
YouTube has an awful algorithms that
like to mess with us anyway we'll see
you guys next week thanks for eating bad
foods and good foods bye I've got two
microphones